how did the opportunity to go on Big
Brother even come your way
CBS called and I said no way sounds
ridiculous when you're you sorry when
you're you everyone else in Hollywood
they have agents and whatever like I
don't have an agent he's clear no they
called me and said you want to do this I
laughed I said no way and then they
called me again and said they're going
on the Bill Maher show can we meet you
after the Bill Maher show and then so
then Tom and Sharron came and met me
after the Bill Maher show and then after
I listened to their pitch you know I'm a
sucker for pitches and so I said yes Wow
yeah easy first date actually are you
nervous about being confined in a house
with crazy celebrity people no I'm not
nervous at all I mean I probably should
be nervous but I think I left a nervous
gene somewhere up in heaven I don't know
I don't really get that nervous who
would you hate to be stuck in a house
with and who is your dream celebrity
alliance my dream celebrity alliance
would probably be like Sly Stallone you
baby or John Travolta yeah yeah those
are you know boyhood idols and so that
would be like cool celebrity alliance
okay
biggest fear you have entering the house
leaving your cell phones being away from
all right well yeah you know look I met
totally even right now I sort of missed
my family so I would say missing my
family is like the biggest downer of the
whole thing yeah but the coolest part
about it so far is meeting new people
yeah I love meeting new people so I'm
looking forward to that
now how competitive are you uh yeah I'm
very competitive but I'm more
collaborative competitive and so this is
a game of elimination so I don't really
play well to a game of elimination in my
life you know I've always played on a
team or team sport so this will be a new
thing for me but then again I worked in
the White House and so that's sort of a
elimination game too so Oh you think
about presidential politics in general
that is an elimination game right so
there's a lot of backstabbing and people
campaigning against each other or being
critical of each other and so there's
elements of that in the house
are you good at reading people like
right from the get-go I would say that
probably one of my better skills is
assessing Talent pretty good at that so
listen a lot of people go on these kinds
of shows Dancing with the Stars survivor
big brother and then on the way out
something pops in their career they get
another movie role or they get you know
a book deal or whatever like what is it
you're hoping I don't know how this
serves you really you know what it's fun
you know for me I'm like the why not
person as opposed to the why person so
somebody asked me to do something I
think it's cool I'm always saying why
not so no idea where this leads and
actually don't care I'm focused on the
moment and living in the present and I
would like to last longer than a mooch
which is 11 days okay so if I last sort
of to mooches that means I'm getting
close to the end I'm possibly winning
you're good I love that did you reach
out to anyone from Season one for advice
no although I am arosa
I'm you know good friends and amarosa
and all she says you got to do this
you'll love it you'll you know you'll
think it's a great time no did she give
you any advice though for like how many
yeah really we didn't talk about the
advice as much as the yeah yeah well I I
know her moves you know I've got I've
got some good coaching from her by
observing her over the years you know I
know her moves he's got some good moves
what is your strategy for winning well I
mean it seems like the people that win
have some level of cunning but they also
don't upset their fellow housemates and
so it seemed like you know like use Ross
as an example from last year
I thought he played like a mass volumes
like the Jedi chess master of like Big
Brother but probably upset a few of his
uh fellow castmates and so forth and I
think that's why I didn't win what are
you gonna do with all that moolah when
you win why pretty sure it's already
been spent by my family and immediate
family external family got a big Italian
family so right I'm stores already spec
now are you worried about the food
situation Italian like Oh what no I mean
no the biggest problem for me is I'm
like a mass of junk food eater so if
there's a lot of junk food in the house
it's gonna be like dangerous situation
for me now
it's only 30 days if it was six months
it's like don't forget about it forget
yeah yeah exactly you are not the first
person from the white house to compete
what do you think that dealing with that
part of your life you know what do you
what skills do you think it's given you
to go far on Big Brother well I mean
again like unfortunately in Washington
the reason why America hates Washington
is that it's a zero-sum game and so
people are winning and losing and so the
reason why I like business is that it's
a win-win situation you know where you
can create an opportunity for everybody
and everybody wins and shares the pie
but Washington they try to kill each
other so unfortunately Big Brother's a
elimination game a little bit like
washing similar now are you nervous at
all about people having cameras on you
24/7 because you are someone that's sort
of studious and like always pulled
together and like America is about to
see you in your deep PJ's you know pull
together excuse me
I'm always pulled together and I mean I
don't really know the only person that
came to press day in a suit and tie
yeah well that's part of casting right I
mean I think people know me in the suit
and tie but trust me I got a ton of
casual clothes in my suit going out I
got I got a hoodie I may have some
interesting slippers I may have some
missing glasses
did anyone help you pack you know yeah
my wife thank God yeah honey thank you
for packing baby because you know I'm
totally clueless on this right this is
good stuff is gonna be throwing
everywhere though one time this is a
mess but that's fine yeah um I'm more
like Oscar than Felix not that you asked
I'm very excited for you I'm nervous
everyone this is I think the best season
of Big Brother in casting that we've
ever seen celebrity or not so you know
all the cast I know everyone that's
gotten and so when you look at don't
have to tell me who's on it but when you
look at the composition you're like okay
that's an interesting dynamic oh it's
incredible
okay guess so I'm looking forward to it
but I think here's what I think is gonna
happen with you I think you're gonna
find out the radar for a minute and then
you're gonna start your Washington Mind
Tricks and you might take the whole
thing
Washington Mind Tricks I was only there
for 11 days it's like I didn't get the
PhD and watch into Mind Tricks days you
know what I'm talking about I do know
you're talking
when I pull out the lightsaber you know
it's trouble
[Music]